we're asked to simplify 12 plus and then
parentheses 5 minus 1 times 3 to the
second power or 3 squared minus 8
divided by the square root or really the
principal root of 4. now whenever you
see something like this you really just
want to put your brain into order of
operations mode and just to remind
ourselves the top priority goes to
parentheses so i'll just draw some
parentheses there then after that we do
exponents and in exponents we also
consider square roots to be an exponent
so
after parentheses we then worry about
things that look like you know a to the
b power or things that look like
that have a radical on them you'll learn
the future that the square root is
really raising something to the one-half
power that's why it's the same thing as
an exponent and then we do
multiplication and division
multiplication and division and then
finally you do addition and subtraction
you finally do addition and subtraction
so let's apply that to this over here so
we have one set of parentheses right
there you have that parenthesis and
inside you have 5 minus 1. so we want to
evaluate that first of all so 5 minus 1
is 4 so our problem becomes
12
12 plus the 5 minus 1 is 4
times
3
squared minus 8
divided by
the positive square root of 4 the
principal root of 4.
now we got all our parentheses out of
the way do we see any exponents here do
we see any exponents we're at this stage
now well i have this three to the second
power three squared and i also have the
square root of four so let's evaluate
those next
three to the second power is nine three
that's the same thing as three times
three
so let me write that down just as a
review 3 to the second power is equal to
3 times 3 which is equal to 9. it is not
equal to 3 times 2. it's 3 times 3.
so 3 squared is 9. so put that 9 there
and the square root of 4 so the square
root of 4 i'll do it down here the
square root of 4 what times itself or
what positive number times or
non-negative number i should say times
itself is equal to 4. what's 2
right this is the same thing as the
square root of 2 times 2 which is equal
to
2.
so this the principal root of 4 is 2
and then we have everything else there
we have the
12
plus this 4
plus 4
times
this 9 minus 8 divided by that 2 right
there
now what's next well we're we we're done
with the x parenthesis and exponents now
we go to multiplication and division and
is that going on anywhere well sure we
have this multiplication right over
there and then we have this division
right over there so let's evaluate those
next so 4 times 9 is 36
36 and 8 divided by 2 is 4.
so we are left with 12
12 plus 36
minus 8 divided by 2 which is 4. and now
we're finally at this stage of our order
of operations so we can just evaluate
what left to right what is 12 plus 36 12
plus 36 i'll do this right here 12 plus
36 is 48 so we have 48 minus 4
and when you evaluate that 48 minus 4 is
just 44 and we're all done